тобто щоб багато не буває просто в день
моделі
БПЛА вони дешевші і доступніші а от ніч
оця модель Вона дорога тому що ну це
можна сказати одне з
найновіших розробок Тому що тут хороший
тепловізійний зум і для нічної роботи я
думаю що мало є систем які можуть по
конкурувати в мобільності і в
ефективності от саме з маттріксом тому я
дуже вдячний і сподіваюсь що вона себе
точно відпрацює навіть не Сподіваюся
може гарантувати що там Хлопці вже з
досвідом це не те що
минула весна коли багато хто не розумів
що буде далі я вже мовчу при 14-й рік
коли Вибачте ми в резинових тапках
ходили в бой це правда то тепер все на
іншому рівні Я бачив системы Посейдон
для артилерійських бригад - це взагалі
космос артилерійський бригади Це просто
основна зброя зброя Перемоги Ну кожен
виконує просто свою роботу Я думаю що і
просто нам щоб ви розуміли просто от
комплекс Посейдон для нашої роботи він
ну не потрібен це забагато це все одно
що їздити в магазин на Танкі але для
роботи дивізіону саме от така машинка
буде дуже доречна я Петро Олексійович
вдячний за дякую не тільки за це я
ж слідкую ви знаєте і в мене отут
планшет тут телефон так сталося що я
можу швидко формулювати думки Я навіть
дикі деякі пости писав вам скажу активне
бойові я там Сиджу собі тримаюся за
ствол там щось пишу ну так сталося тому
що я так і не став палити так само собою
вживати ні Мені треба кудись трясі
вдівати я його туди от весь на соціальні
мережі і на Зараз на жаль на війні Ми
хочемо скористатися цією можливістю і
прорекламувати сторінку гнома сторінку
Валерія про запаси це дуже-дуже круто
Спасибі Заходьте подивитесь обіцяє буде
цікаво